not doing my job if I don't bring up the
Big Lebowski that is more than a film
that is more than a movie it has become
sort of an iconic I would see piece of
Americana
wouldn't you say The Big Lebowski the
dude and that film wonderful it's just
absolutely wonderful and I have to say
the one thing I've never talked to you
about is the dream sequence The Big
Lebowski is one of my favorite pieces of
film ever I love that dream sequence is
wonderful when the dude is completely
out of it and he has this crazy dream
that revolves around bowling
I need a terrible I made a terrible
error that day you made an error that
day yeah I thought oh it would be nice
to invite my wife and young girls to the
set one day yeah my girls were you know
about seven eight nine so we're in there
and I chose that day that you're talking
about the dream sequence kind of a Busby
Berkeley so my show it let me just show
it then everyone know exactly remember
what we're talking about this is just a
quick clip from that dream sequence in
The Big Lebowski
[Music]
a mile straight
see
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so that's the day that was an accident
you have a ball right along with that
same day that we filmed that we also
filmed this Busby Berkeley deal with the
girls with all the you know bowling pin
hats every that be fun for the girl
mm-hmm then they get there and I said no
wait a minute Jeff what the hell are you
thinking this is the day when you get on
that little skateboard we'd practice
that you know and you're pulled and
you're looking up at all these ladies
vaginas you know what are you thinking
you know yeah this is not the day to
have no no yeah so I I take photographs
when I'm on the set with this crazy wide
Lux camera it's a panning still camera
take this very long you know panning
shots so I went up to the head bowling
pin Corinne that's what they recalled
and I say yeah this is a wonderful photo
op do you mind if I take a picture you
know why you're going under well I'm
going in for the rehearsal you know and
she says to me oh by all means do I give
them my little skateboard mm-hmm and
like you know get my camera ready and I
look up and there beneath the leotard
are these Tufts of pubic hair coming out
of this leotard that I can amazing
and I go okay and I push my camera and
the lenses and as I go the next lady's
unit vagina whatever you know I'm not
gonna support ah it's like more ornate
and it's just you know and then the next
one is you know goes more and it's the
whole you know it's the forest and what
they had done they went to the makeup
man and had crepe hair okay they packed
it's okay alright so they're playing a
joke on it and thank God like my wife
Sue and my girls they were all into and
you in on it so joke on the dude they
were of it the whole family was in on
this joke it was one of those vaginas we
had this trick somewhere I think on my
site I believe I had that pictures
available for anyone yeah you guys go
look that up I got I got to show these
really quickly cuz we should be and I
these are the actual gel sandals that
you wore as the dude these are the axes
[Applause]
twelve those might you might stretch it
man yeah I wouldn't stretch him on you
know I wouldn't but that's just
absolutely those were mine and when they
came when we when we dressed up the dude
we went to my closet and got a lot of
stuff oh really
these were actually he yours remind
you've hung onto these these are gonna
be in the so do you ever just wear these
around and not as the dude but is me I
think you've become the dude
you